[Music]
am i looking forward to tasting some
chocolate of course it's chocolate
why is it wrapped like a present
oh my god
it's a kitten oh my god it's kitchens oh
my goodness
why this is the best day of my life oh
this isn't chocolate oh my god hello
this is so much better than chocolate oh
my god these are so precious oh you're
making noises oh he's so small
i care
so little about chocolate right now
they're so fuzzy where did you tell you
oh we just have one i thought i didn't
have a table you are mine and we are
leaving
cats are the best
if you bite the mic we can't use this
audio cats are great because you work
for their attention but they also will
love you so unconditionally we hold dogs
up as you know being like man's best
friend there are a lot of cats that can
give you just as much love and that need
homes you just gotta find a cat that's
catered to your personality if you want
a chill cat they're out there if you
want a little demon like this guy
they're out there there's so many cats
and shelters that need homes so if you
can you should foster them or adopt them
anytime i open a box i'm hoping that
there are kittens in it and this time it
was true i'll take all of them don't
worry i'll have all the cats
i like to wrestle with my cats
with my hands you know not my full body
i'm not a
maniac